one week ago the Los Angeles Dodgers
announced that they would be celebrating
their 10th Annual lgbtq plus Pride night
on June 16th by giving an award to a
group of drag queens baseball club
planned to bestow the honor of community
Heroes and they're going to bestow it
onto the Los Angeles chapter of the
sisters of Perpetual Indulgence for
those who are blessedly unfamiliar with
this group The Sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence are drag queens who dress up
like sacrilegious caricatures of nuns
now they in fact make a mockery of the
whole process of becoming and being a
nun in the Catholic church just like
actual nuns new members of the sisters
of professional Indulgence are called
postulants and then they graduate to
novices and then they become sisters at
the group's founding actually they used
to use actual religious habits that had
been worn by Catholic nuns as their
costumes and these days the men take on
names like sister erotica psychotica
Sister Mary effing Poppins and sister
magically delicious